y comenzamos entonces revista de prensa
de hoy martes de rosa bienvenida buena
mañana vamos a empezar hablando pues por
supuesto del conflicto esta guerra entre
rusia y ucrania pero luego pero vamos a
empezar con deportes de rosa porque una
de las sanciones fue que la fifa y la
uefa champions league expulsó a rusia de
todos sus campeonatos y luego por
supuesto vamos a ver todo el análisis
político que eventualmente hacemos pero
empezamos hoy por deportes rosa buenos
días raúl exactamente hoy nos hemos
fijado en la prensa deportiva porque
como no podía ser de otra forma muchos
medios de comunicación especializados en
deportes se hacen eco no de esta
expulsión de los equipos rusos de los
campeonatos internacionales aquí vemos
el equipo de francia que dice tarjeta
roja no expulsión para rusia y luego
tenemos dos medios deportivos españoles
no sé si los podemos ver aquí el as que
dice fuera con la cara pintada con la
bandera rusa de stefan no digamos
probablemente de la selección
y también él marca rusia fuera de todo
con los logos de las distintas
competiciones
internacionales en las que ya no podrá
participar el deporte castiga a putin un
tema muy importante que incluso vamos a
ampliar con juán pupiales y un analista
en deportes a las 7 50 de la mañana
ahora bogotá para que todos estén
pendientes pero seguimos hablando rosa
del análisis del salto para hablar ahora
de la oposición de la guerra dentro de
rusia porque hay rusos que se oponen a
esto cierto rosa efectivamente y es un
discurso que hemos oído mucho que ésta
ha sido una decisión adoptada por el
presidente que no necesariamente cuenta
con el apoyo de la población civil
precisamente el salto de españa recuerda
que según la organización o vd una ong
financiada entre otras por la unión
europea desde que se declaró la guerra
el 24 de este mes de febrero más de seis
mil personas han sido detenidas en el
marco de protestas contra la guerra y
que concretamente este domingo 27 de
febrero se produjeron más de 2.000
detenciones en este mismo marco de
protestas contra la invasión de ucrania
y que la presión atañe también a los
medios de comunicación se han cerrado
distintos medios con una retórica
crítica con la guerra y que
particularmente el regulador ruso de
telecomunicaciones indica orden a los
medios de comunicación autorizados que
usen el término operación especial como
hemos venido comentando en lugar de
guerra o invasión raúl rosa y también
precisamente eso lo destaca la prensa
rusa también el apoyo popular de la
invasión a ucrania ellos dicen pues eso
todo lo contrario que más destacan desde
moscú y desde kiev efectivamente el
medio védomosti
lo que hace es una lectura muy distinta
de hecho se centra en un adelanto de
informaciones por parte del director de
la del centro de investigación de la
opinión pública de rusia que asegura que
según una encuesta que se está llevando
a cabo en estos momentos el
68% de los rusas apoyan la operación
militar especial en ucrania y que la
popularidad de vladimir putin va en
aumento y que todavía aumentará más
y logra ganar rápidamente esta guerra y
puede reestructurar la economía de forma
que no le afecten tan fuerte de forma
tan impactante las sanciones económicas
por otro lado del mediodía asegura que
este discurso que está teniendo tanto
ucrania como occidente de que esta
agresión no fue provocada por kiev es
falsa y que en los últimos 30 años desde
que ucrania se independizó de la unión
soviética ha ido buscando lo que le pasa
hoy adoptando una posición anti rusa y
por último el kiev independent está
haciendo un minuto a minuto de lo que
pasa en kiev en esta guerra y asegura
una de las noticias que destacamos es
que según a la rada el parlamento de
ucrania se han visto ya tropas
bielorrusas entrando en territorio
ucraniano para apoyar a las fuerzas
militares rusas ayer mencionábamos ros a
la decisión de bloquear es peligrosa
turey de youtube de los canales de
youtube dentro de la unión europea ya se
hizo efectiva esa medida rosa pues así
es estas plataformas a ella decido a lo
que pidió ursula von der leyen no es
silenciar lo que ella considera una
maquinaria de propaganda del kremlin y
ya desde hoy mismo no se puede no se
puede acceder a los canales de youtube
de russia today ni de sputnik en la
unión europea eso también sucede con
otras plataformas como facebook o
incluso dictó que esta plataforma china
que también ha bloqueado los vídeos de
estos medios de comunicación estatales
pues en la unión europea por supuesto
tanto rusia today como sputnik considere
consideran esto una violación a la
libertad de prensa y a la libertad de
expresión pero la comisión europea
considera que no se pueden considerar
estas plataformas de medios de
comunicación russia today va a llevar el
caso a los tribunales y asegura que
hasta el momento ninguna autoridad
judicial ni ninguna agencia de
regulación les había perseguido por
calumnias a mentes rápidamente rosas
cerramos con la pregunta que se hace el
correo internacional pertinente comparar
a putin un hitler pues hacen un repaso
un análisis de todas estas comparaciones
que hemos oído tanto he leído tantas
veces desde qué esta guerra en ucrania
hay quienes dicen que si tanto por la
retórica como por la estrategia militar
en el 'new yorker' se leía por ejemplo
las afirmaciones delirantes de putin
dificultan no compararlo con hitler en
la estrategia militar hablan de la en
este caso el uso del caballo de troya
alegando a la presencia de minorías
respectivamente alemanas y en este caso
rusas pues en checoslovaquia en los
sudetes y ahora pues en el este de
ucrania para introducirse como un
caballo de troya y penetrar en las
defensas de sus objetivos también hablan
de que putin ve débil la unión europea y
sabe que no quiere entrar en una guerra
abierta con rusia y para terminar hay
quien dice que no se puede llegar a
hacer esta comparación que ningún
dictador de este siglo 21 puede ser tan
cruel como fue hitler y que también se
usó esta retórica de comparar pues en
ese caso de justificar la invasión de
irak el gobierno de saddam hussein nada
con el régimen nazi que supo provocó esa
desastrosa invasión de irak en 2000
precisamente rosa putin dice que el nazi
excelencia y que va a desclasificar
ucrania con esta invasión eso realizamos
en segundos con nuestro primer invitado
el día rosa